- We're gonna get Kylie Jenner lips.
- To me, that just means like
really big, full, pouty lips.
And I feel like I have pretty thin lips
so I think it's gonna be
a pretty drastic change.
- I've never thought about
making my lips bigger.
- I am fascinated by Kylie Jenner's lips,
I want them very badly.
My lips, I've been told
from some lovely people
on Instagram, are very thin apparently.
- Yeah, so she's kind of saying like
this is an alternative
to getting lip injections
which seems like a good idea.
- I'm really intrigued to see
why I need all this stuff.
- Okay, she's doing it like way up here
I feel like it's gonna touch my nose.
- Oh god.
- Got myself a little mustache.
- You're supposed to make
like a weird butt out of your liner.
- It's so off center.
Okay, I need to fix this.
- No, I could not imagine
doing this every day.
- And then you kinda fill in a little bit.
- Who has time for this?
- I don't know if I like this.
- Okay so now,
we're gonna fill in everything.
Oh, and you have to make sure it's matte.
- So you can't use shiny lipstick
because it'll reveal your true lip line.
- Wait, mine looks so different from her.
- Like what if you have to eat something
or drink something, like, what do you do?
- Men like this, is this attractive?
- I am Miranda Sings right now,
I am her, this is it.
(laughing)
- This is scary.
- So you get your concealer and you put
a little dollop on this, like,
tiny-teeny angled brush.
- I don't know, I think she said to use
some foundation maybe to
make it pop a little more.
- Oh my god, wait, this is
literally the last step.
This is like, how it's supposed to look.
- This looks fake.
- I mean, the concealer is like mixing
with the pink, and like
it's just an extra line.
- It's hard to tell what I look like.
Let me see from afar.
- I think maybe if I
had a proper skill-set
I'd do it again, maybe.
- I can barely even do a cat eye.
- I mean like, I already have
lipstick all over my face.
- I don't feel like I can walk out of here
and be like, check me out guys, like,
I'm totally me right now.
- I like makeup, I just
wish I was better at it.
- I mean there's no way you can kiss
a guy, or a girl, or
whoever you want to kiss.
- If I like went on like
a date with somebody
or met somebody new and
I took off my make up,
they'd be like, what the fuck,
like you're totally different.
- Just get plastic surgery.
- [Brunette Woman] How does she pose,
she's like, and looks
like really concerned.
And like you put on those
like really pointy nails.
- I have beautiful lips and
no parental supervision.